it's been a while since we've done one
of these I'm Greg I'm Kyle fan Theory TV
has joined me today the leader is true
of all the people who react over at fan
Theory TV a whole bunch of shows go
check them out and harass you do you
like Family Guy
I love Family Guy anything from Seth
MacFarlane I don't really do try not to
laugh challenges like a lot of my other
fellow reactors out there but when it's
a Family Guy one I'm kind of drawn to
them they're really difficult to not
laugh at there are times I've cried one
time breathe one time I started like
tearing up because something was so
funny it started coming out of my eyes
we're going to do a cat Alvarado that's
great
this one does dark humor compilation
idea for the challenge I'm excited for
this challenge now Kyle
if you end up laughing and just reset
okay okay there's be like I lost I'm
gonna laugh I hate it when people do
that just reset the serious business
okay if you are
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
listen Tiffani you seem really great I
need to come clean with you about
something because I have herpes
really yeah well that's okay
I mean if we're careful about it it
shouldn't be an issue and the truth is I
like you so much I do anything to make
this work oh god I'm so happy to hear
that love it people same way you know
you know I know this is crazy and like
super sudden but will you catch the kid
I hate to replace Chris thank you for
wearing a baseball cap hi Stewie there's
the kitchen being gripped by Arnold
Schwarzenegger yeah I'll do an iced tea
shut the door all right my old school
anyway well I know what he was doing and
I don't like it I think it fancy guys
like you only drink in hotels the hotels
threw me up
I used a mustard bottle the right Dallas
Portland's a dick on the wall oh yeah I
get that want you to hotel but it was
pee and I didn't write anything 20
minutes wait you still use a pager you
know well we thought once we got Steve
Jobs in heaven we'd all get iPhones but
you never showed up
Oh
I have a headache forgot that sometimes
try not to laughs hurt my head I have to
project the energy whatever
physiological reactions I am having
maybe it's the effect of emotional
repression that's the time to cancel
Family Guy people not woke enough tell
you that much
definitely not it's not good not good
cancel it
comedy shouldn't exist on that note -
comedy should be canceled doesn't do
anyone any direction we're definitely
going i don't like comedy never did
never will
Family Guy is only a further
representation of what's wrong with our
society that was some funny [ __ ] though
I thought I've seen most of Family Guy
but I did it know like 90% of those
jokes I'm a lot is like I I just don't
recall those family guys gotten way
darker in the last decade well if we
gotta push the boundary so they got a do
they got a push it to the limit when
they kill Meg in that scene I was like
hold it together that was the funniest
one the jokes about bullying doors
maegor's so funny that's great about
Family Guy is the only reason a lot
either funny is because this is not
live-action
most of the jokes they do only work as
it's a cartoon even just like the
dialogue-driven ones but because of the
fact that it's yeah he's sick as hell
it's weird how what not hilarious in
life it's weird how one medium changes
that whole perspective on everything
yeah somebody's wearing dark humor them
some of these were just humorous some of
them were super racist some of them were
kind of awful I have the Diary of Anne
Frank good thing no one's ever gonna
read this
oh well we did it we have completed a
try not to laugh challenge do you feel
good about yourself um a little nauseous
actually right there's causes like a
physical pain it kind of does yeah I
forgot why I don't really do these that
often it's also weird right because
people are watching this for us working
really hard not to laugh yeah weird
concerts a really strange concept but
for some reason people love it and I say
yes YouTube is full of interesting
people some people watch people watching
trailers we're freakin bizarre all right
well this came from the channel best
tuned clips make sure to subscribe to
them as soon as you can follow Kyle on
YouTube hey Kyle yes Greg I want to do a
patron the day shout-out well good lady
joy B I would love to who are we picking
shout out goes to Katie Ann Katey Ann
you're always so sweet and you've been
such a support to the channel are you
you're killing it I feel actually I kind
of get the impression Katie Ann might
have a dark sense of humor
because she is very loving she's very
harmful she's poetic very creative she
writes when I say poetic and I mean that
literally shoot writes poetry has her
own movie blog site but she's covered in
tats so I'm assuming she's a dark person
I don't have a single tattoo I never
actually something with a tattoo I
assume they have a lot of darkness in
their soul or you know she's just trying
to add layers to who she is not
traumatising childhood that's what I've
concluded I'm sorry about your childhood
I'm sorry about everything you've gone
through and now you act out by
disgracing your body it's a sin it's
against the Catholic Church sin to get
tattoos you
tattoos many I do not have a tattoo
because I am pure and holy and Katie I
am sorry that you have not met my
standard of the heavenly requirements
I'm sorry Kyle chose you this is
[Laughter]